revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Rosa Pérez mateu bienvenida
buena mañana de miércoles vamos a
empezar esta revista de prensa con un
análisis político de vox.com que plantea
Tres formas de la que llama cruel escala
de Putin sobre los civiles en Ucrania
Buenos días Raúl exactamente este
análisis de Daniel drexler parte de la
premisa de que está escalada de la
ofensiva rusa atacando objetivos
objetivos civiles no va a llevar a
ningún lado y que está condenada al
fracaso Dice porque por un lado está
aislando Rusia todavía más de sus
potenciales aliados o de sus aliados en
la comunidad internacional estamos
hablando particularmente de China y de
la India que recordemos este análisis
hace De hecho especial
énfasis en el episodio que tuvo lugar en
la última sesión especial de la asamblea
general de Naciones Unidas en que se
votó una emoción que pretendía ordenar
la anexión a Rusia de los territorios de
lugans jerson y saporiya de hecho la
condena no obtuvo amplia mayoría y Rusia
solo estuvo apoyada por cuatro países
velarus Corea del Norte Siria y
Nicaragua y de hecho precisamente no lo
recalcable es que tanto china como la
India se abstuvieron de condenar la
anexión pero tampoco digamos condenaron
la condena bien en todo caso también
señala este artículo que este esta
escalada en la ofensiva está provocando
que los aliados de ucraniaen bien más
armamento la otan de hecho y que por
otro lado el pueblo ucraniano también
tenga más determinación en su
resistencia ante la invasión de Rusia
Entonces digamos rusa que tesis plantea
este texto porque estaría aumentando el
kremín su ofensiva en Ucrania lo analiza
desde tres planos digamos por un lado en
el Internacional dice que para responder
a este aislamiento no que comentábamos
un momento que lo que está intentando el
kremlin es que atacar civiles se vea
como un ejemplo de que no le importa
usar toda la brutalidad a su disposición
y que eso podría significar no podría
dejar entrever que no le importaría como
ya dicho en anteriores ocasiones pues
usar armas nucleares y que está
utilizando esta amenaza para forzar una
eventual la mesa de diálogo en que se le
conceda básicamente el reconocimiento de
lo que busca entre otras cosas Pues el
reconocimiento de estos territorios
anexionados por otro lado en el plano
doméstico o interno dice que bueno los
lentos avances en la guerra o incluso
los retrocesos no que hemos visto ante
la contraofensiva ucraniana están
generando muchísimas acríticas alrededor
de Putin y que precisamente aumentar la
brutalidad es una forma de mostrarse
fuerte pero luego también hay un plano
interesante con el que termina este
análisis y es precisamente el plano
psicológico eh básicamente lo que
defiende este texto es que Putin ya
tiene poco que perder no que se metió en
esta guerra que parecía en un primer
momento una Guerra Relámpago y que pues
ante las dificultades que está
enfrentando este artículo aplica la
teoría de las perspectivas de Daniel y
vamos básicamente esa teoría defiende
que una persona es reacia a tomar
decisiones arriesgadas cuando va ganando
pero que es más tolerante arriesgar
arriesgarse cuando está perdiendo y que
por lo tanto Putin está en esta
encrucijada Pero Raúl añadimos una cosa
y es que recordemos que Putin ya había
comentado en anteriores ocasiones que
respondería con todos a los medios a su
disposición ante un ataque a su
territorio y que recordemos que la
escalada de la ofensiva tuvo lugar
después de la explosión en el puente de
kerch en crimea que es un territorio que
Rusia considera pues suyo continuamos
con un tema relacionado con Rusia
hablamos en la polémica amistad entre el
líder italiano Silvio y el presidente
usó la mirbutó una amistad que ha
ocupado titulares alrededor del mundo de
nuevo desde ayer que se filtró un
polémico audio del jefe de Forza Italia
exactamente ahí es que recordemos que en
Italia están en plenas negociaciones
para un acuerdo de gobierno encontré la
formación a posfacista de Georgia
hermanos de Italia la liga de Mateo
salvini y Forza Italia de Silvio
berlusconi que según anunció ayer y ha
conseguido que su fuerza tenga el
Ministerio de exteriores así como el de
Justicia pero en este contexto como bien
decías se filtró a la prensa una
conversación que el cavaliere habría
tenido con su partido en el parlamento
el lunes y en esta conversación
precisamente hablaba de cómo se ha
vuelto a acercar con el presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin en entre otras cosas
Expreso su preocupación por si Ucrania
entra a la otan lo que dijo se
convertiría se desencadenaría una guerra
mundial pero también dio detalles de lo
que han sido digamos sus últimas sus
últimos encuentros sus últimas
relaciones con ruso escuchemos a
continuación un breve fragmento
he retomado el contacto con el
presidente Putin por mi cumpleaños me
mandó 20 botellas de vodka y una carta
muy dulce y yo le respondí con botellas
de lambrusco y una carta igual de Dulce
soy el primero de sus cinco amigos
no que lo filtró precisamente el
periódico italiano la prese Gracias Rosa
como siempre por esta revista de prensa
el día de hoy mañana con más pasamos a
saludar ahora a nuestra primera invitada